[Music]
we are entering what I call the next
golden era of space exploration the
first golden era was back in the 1960s
but it was unsustainable in 1966 the
NASA budget consumed five percent of the
entire federal budget it was impossible
to sustain that level of spending now
it's about 0.5% however now with the
injection of new ideas fresh enthusiasm
from the private sector from Silicon
Valley billionaires we have a whole new
different landscape just recently we had
that sensational launch of the Falcon
Heavy rocket financed by zero zero
amount of taxpayers dollars and it shows
you that the economics have changed and
now with the introduction of reusable
rockets we're not talking about opening
up the heavens to perhaps a whole new
economic landscape that is ten percent
the cost of the past to put me in orbit
around the earth costs about $10,000 a
pound that's my weight in gold think of
my body made out of solid gold that's
what it takes me to put just to go
around the earth in near orbit to go to
the moon would cost about a hundred
thousand dollars a pound to put me on
Mars will cost at least a million
dollars a pound that is unsustainable
and that's where the reusable rockets
come in because we're not talking about
dropping the cost by a factor of 10
instead of 10 thousand dollars a pound
SpaceX wants to bring it down to $1,000
a pound December of 2019 NASA will send
the SLS booster rocket and the Orion
module around the moon on a robotic
unmanned mission just a few years after
that the first astronauts will go back
to the moon after a 50-year gap and by
late in the next decade we hope to have
a lunar orbiter a lunar orbiter that
gives us a permanent presence in outer
space not just the space station but a
lunar orbiter and from that we want to
go all the way to Mars
and so nASA has already now look at the
blueprints made by Boeing aircraft
concerning what it would take to send
probes to the Mars in fact we may even
have a traffic accident around Mars
because of the fact that SpaceX not to
be outdone they're proposing their big
rocket to take us not just to the moon
with the dragon space capsule and the
and the Falcon Heavy rocket but a new
rocket the bf our rocket to take us all
the way to Mars even bypassing the lunar
orbiter we also have a new vision
emerging for Elon Musk of SpaceX is to
create a multi-planet species however
for Jeff Bezos of Amazon he wants to
make earth into a park so that all the
Heavy Industries all the pollution goes
into outer space and Jeff Bezos wants to
set an Amazon type delivery system
connecting the earth to the moon I was
talked to Carl Sagan and he said that
because the earth is in the middle of a
shooting gallery of asteroids and comets
and meteors it's inevitable that we will
be hit with a planet Buster something
like what hit the dinosaurs 65 million
years ago
we need an insurance policy now he was
clear to say that we're not talking
about moving the population of the earth
into outer space that costs too much
money and we have problems of our own on
the earth like global warming we have to
deal with those problems on the earth
not fleeing in outer space but as an
insurance policy we have to make sure
that that humans become a two-planet
species these are the words of Carl
Sagan and now of course Elon Musk he
wants to put up to a million a million
colonists on the planet Mars sent to
Mars by his rockets financed by a
combination of public and private
funding and remember he has the vision
the energy and the checkbook to make
many of these ideas into a reality
[Music]